joining us now the chairman of the
commons health and social care committee
and of course former health secretary
himself jeremy hunt mr hunt lovely to
have you on the program i i wonder if we
might just start by giving an overview
of of the rep of the committee's
conclusions i mean it's it's been pretty
clear for some time that there needed to
be some reform of nhs litigation
thank you good morning neil um this
might seem a rather sort of technical
area um and it's very important to say
from the outset that the vast majority
of nhs care is is absolutely excellent
totally safe but when things do go wrong
we're very bad at learning from mistakes
and making sure the same thing doesn't
happen again in the future and one of
the reasons is the litigation system we
have which can mean that families have
to wait five six seven years before they
actually get an answer as to whether
they're going to get any compensation
it's absolutely devastating for them and
it costs the nhs over two billion pounds
every year to pay these claims
the biggest hospital in the nhs is
bart's trust
that's more than the entire annual cost
of paying for every single doctor and
nurse in bart's that we're paying in
compensation in litigation costs rather
than on frontline care and that's why
we're saying there needs to be an urgent
overhaul
what then in your minds needs to be done
i mean you're absolutely right to say
that you know lessons haven't been
learned in the past you only need to
look as far as the auckland report for
that so so what needs to be done and be
done pretty quickly
the first thing we say is that the
priority needs to be to learn from
mistakes
and to do that we need to make it much
easier for patients to get compensation
ironically if you make it easier for
people to get compensation you learn
from mistakes and it ends up costing you
less because these things don't then
happen again a few months or years later
and we looked at systems in new zealand
and in sweden which actually end up
costing their health systems about half
what it costs us here in the nhs and
that's because they they just make it
easier for people to access compensation
here you have to prove that a doctor or
nurse has been clinically negligent
before you get any compensation and what
that means is you have a very
adversarial process right from the start
the the medics feel very very defensive
they don't want to talk openly because
they're they're worried that there may
be professional consequences for them
and right from the outset you get a very
negative atmosphere when actually what
everyone wants to do is to be completely
transparent about what happened learn
the mistakes and make sure these
terrible tragedies aren't repeated
and this is the thing isn't it
ultimately at the core of this the nhs
held up by everyone but pretty much
everyone in this country
as one of the things that we are so most
proud of to be british it also has to be
it also has to be mentioned that
mistakes are made mistakes are
compounded by cover-ups i i just wonder
whether or not you think that the system
is hindered or it benefits from the kind
of the decentralized control of the
health service by giving control to kind
of the nhs trust is there more or less
of an attempt by by individual hospitals
to cover up their mistakes
well it's a very good question i'm
generally in favor of giving more
autonomy to hospitals and gp surgeries
just to get on with the job but i think
in this case the law gets in the way and
it makes it very difficult if someone
wants to i mean if you're a doctor or a
nurse and something goes wrong the first
thing you want to do is to be honest
with families about what happened
to be completely open about it
but your lawyers are telling you if you
do that uh you could be hauled in front
of the general medical council uh you
could lose your license to practice you
could cost us huge amounts of money and
there's one other thing that is really
outrageous in the law and really against
the founding principles of the nhs which
is that if the child of a banker
is severely disabled because of a
mistake they will get more compensation
than the child of a cleaner because
extraordinarily the way the law works is
it looks at the likely future earnings
of that child and it decides that the
child of the banker would have been
likely to earn more in the future that
to me goes right against the founding
principle of equality that underlines
the way the nhs works and we should
change that as well
um i wonder mr if we can kind of stay on
your brief such as it is but get you get
your kind of experience as a former
health sector and of course you know
when i'm going with this the high court
decision the high court uh judicial
review yesterday of matt hancock's
decision to move uh people elderly
people from hospitals uh into care homes
the prime minister said yesterday at
pmqs that the government wasn't told of
concerns about asymptomatic transmission
by public health england and that's
nonsense isn't it
well i think the first thing to say is
that the you know to be prime minister
or health secretary in a pandemic is an
incredibly challenging thing you're
having to make decisions very quickly
and you are going to make some mistakes
and i think we have to be reasonable and
think about the context that matt
hancock and boris johnson were operating
in
our select committee looked at this
report in detail and we concluded
similarly to yesterday's judgment that
we should have done much more to learn
from what happened in countries like
germany and hong kong
where when people were sent to care
homes for example in germany they had to
be isolated for three months unless
there was a negative test uh we didn't
do that here that was clearly a mistake
but i think the broader issue and it's
one that i have to bear my share of
responsibility for as well as someone
who has health secretary for six years
is that we just still have not sorted
out problems in the social care system
so when you have a crisis
it always ends up playing second fiddle
to the nhs the focus of if i may say
you'll also the media but the
politicians the civil servants the
system is on hospitals and hospital care
and that's what everyone is thinking
about
and
what happened
i would counter that we probably
wouldn't have known as quickly as we did
what was going on in our care homes if
it wasn't for the media including people
like our people in politics
correspondent nick martin getting in
there i mean the problem is i think i
suppose mr hunt is we can't deal with
this as an abstraction you know by june
of 2020 there were perhaps as many as 30
000 excess deaths and care homes and in
part that was as a result of a decision
taken by the health the then health
secretary seemingly unaware of advice
that if he'd switched on the today
program he'd have heard sir patrick
violence giving
yes i'm sorry i wasn't saying that the
media didn't have a very very important
role during that i was being somewhat
cheeky i was being somewhat cheap
but i think the the interesting thing is
actually if you look at the high court
judgment the advice the health secretary
received from officials
didn't advise him that he should think
about this question of asymptomatic
transmission so there was a kind of
group think in the system that said that
this
virus we were dealing with was going to
be essentially like the flu virus where
you don't think so much about
asymptomatic transmission i think there
are lots and lots of lessons to be
learned but the broader point i really
wanted to make is that until we really
fix the problems in the care system
then i think we're always going to find
the center of gravity in a crisis
remains hospitals and the nhs
and that in this case had devastating
consequences
mr hunt away from away from health
entirely and what do you make of the
reports that one of your parliamentary
colleagues uh one of your conservative
party colleagues i should actually say
um was seen by his colleagues watching
pornography on his mobile phone in the
house of commons chamber
well to be honest i just feel so
disappointed um i'm disappointed that it
it was someone in my party that was
alleged to have done this
but also disappointed for the house of
commons as an institution i have to say
my day-to-day experience as an mp is not
that this kind of thing is happening on
a regular basis but i just feel we
should not be putting female mps through
this kind of ordeal and it's totally and
utterly unacceptable and
clearly we have to have a very big
culture change and um you know and i
hope
if there is some good that comes out of
this it will prompt that culture change
that many people have been calling for
jeremy hunt always great to have you on
the program appreciate your time
thank you